друзі Всім привіт гарні новини
Нестор нелитописец не Нестор Шуфрич це
негідник Він отримав підозру у державній
зраді нарешті сьогодні зранку до нього
прийшли з обшуками дуже багато чого
цікавого знайшли зараз вам покажу і вже
зараз ми знаємо що йому вручена підозра
державна зрада як нарешті СБУ прийшло до
одного з керівників опзж по якому давно
вже в'язниця плаче і як зрадника Шуфрича
нарешті назвали зрадником при тому що
він до сих пір голова комітету з питань
свободи слова Верховної Ради України
просто ідіотизм зараз про все це в
деталях не забудьте підписатися на канал
просуваємо україномовний контент в Ютубі
не забуваємо підписуватись не забуваємо
тиснути лайк палець догори не забуваємо
шерити це відео ділитися їм коментувати
і так друзі Нестор Шуфрич Ранок почався
цікавий Ранок почався з візиту СБУ
значить прийшли до нього в його елітний
маєток в селі Козин елітне село елітний
маєток Ну і в такому повністю в стилі
Пшонка Style русский мир Подивіться
прихожую чи то коридор чи що Це йде
Шуфрич зустрічає гостей з СБУ А позаду
нього закрити поліетиленом фонтан Уявіть
собі всередині будинку фонтан Ну А далі
почалися відкриття які тілі якісь
імундіри і якісь двох главіарли медальки
і він полководец с победой Нестор Шуфрич
и Ветеран вооружённых сил Российской
Федерации и медали в нього є російські і
якісь
такійсь там ну не паспорти громадянина
але паспорти яких значить досягнень
російських не всі цеплять безкінечні
кількості Подивіться на все це ну це
знаєте що можна посміятися А що в нього
знайшли документи що від 2014 року про
так звану автономію класу край парламент
отдельных Донецкой и луганского краев
что за крококие края попутал края берега
я вношу Фреш и подписи стоять медведчука
і Шуфрича нагадаю що Шуфрич кум
медведчука його найближчий друг от така
друзі історія А в чому ж його звинувачує
СБУ що він частина цієї російської
агентурної мережі керівником якої
задумкою СБУ є
сівкович колишній
заступник секретаря Ради національної
безпеки і оборони України людина яка
переховується в Москві До речі людина
чим багаторічним помічником був день
гетьманцев ще один персонаж цього разу
зі слуги народу ну це часто
перетинається слуга народу опзж в них
така любов велика це це ми можемо
спостерігати дуже часто чекаємо коли
прийдуть і де гетьманцева ну а Поки
прийшли до Шуфрича Сьогодні би
відбуваються 45 обшуків у Шуфрича його
помічників е-е значить в інших
приміщеннях які йому належать СБУ його
підозрює в тому що він дуже активно
працював цій мережі савковича проти
України в тому числі в інформаційній
сфері ну всі ці твердження про один
народ і все інше ну це точно це правда
ми всі це чудово знаємо що саме це
Шуфрич і завжди казав подивіться відео
як він не може сказати що Путін вбиває
українців не може сказати з ким війна Ну
і взагалі нічого сказати Не може
послухайте не стор Шуфрич не може
назвати Росію агресором
А ви вважаєте Росію нашим ворогом
пані
Віталію ви знаєте я є політикою з
великим досвідом і не переконаний що
Путін убився скажи
те президент України ви боїтеся А тепер
от Нова Ідея від опзжопця
нагадаю що ще до 24 лютого Він дуже
активно включався на російській ЗМІ і
навіть після 24 лютого вже встиг туди
включитися до всіх цих скабейових
соловйових і же з ними Ну А далі коли
Путін не взяв Київ за три дні то шуфрі
швиденько перевзувся сказав значить що
все ПСЖ До свидания разом з іншими
повиходив з нього і тепер значить
переховується в цій платформі за життя
та мир яку вони йти посварили унікальна
в цьому всьому те до речі Шуфрич там
звичайно в Криму має власність
переформив її за російськими правилами
Подивіться Ось так виходячи з сервісу
Яндекс Карти не добут шуфричів виглядав
до анексії
А це вже після у 2016-му
[музика]
та 19-му роках
тепер порівнюємо на відео
ліворуч зйомки коледжу з Крим Реалії на
початку 2021 на які потрапив маєток
родини Шуфрича праворуч наче свіжі
зйомки напередодні нового року бачимо За
останні півроку територія дещо змінилася
будівельне сміття
[музика]
і табличка з написом приватна власність
хто тепер опікується цим недобудом
навесні Минулого року вступив у дію указ
Путіна який забороняє іноземним
громадянам якими за версією російського
президента також є українці володіти
землею у Криму
чи перереєстрували шуфричі цю територію
за російськими законами якщо це так за
логікою ми мали би бачити дані про це в
російській кадастровій карті Але на
відміну від сусідніх ділянок система не
дозволяє отримати актуальні дані про
власників землі шуфричу не можна навіть
дізнатись її кадастровий номер чи може
бути так що земля таки була оформлена
але ми цього не бачимо на російських
картах ми запитали про це У Івана
голонова російського
журналіста-розслідувача який багато
працює із місцевими реєстрами
когда участка книжок каким-то Хм
влиятельном людям которые хотели бы это
скрыть ми продовжили спроби сертифікації
цього майна в реєстрі вручну метод
підбору ймовірних цифр кадастрових
номерів спрацював Таким чином ми знайшли
в російському реєстрі всі кримські
ділянки та об'єкти нерухомості придбані
родиною Шуфрича ідентичними за
параметрами розміщення площею та іншими
деталями ось наприклад основна будівля
маєтку в українському реєстрі площу
чотири з половиною тисячі квадратних
метрів з готовністю у 71%, аналогічні
дані і в російському реєстрі унікальна
друзі в цьому всьому Те що
при цьому шуфріч з його колегами
залишався народним депутатом України ну
це просто божевілля російський Агент про
якого це абсолютно всім відомий було
зрозуміло але нічого він сидів
тихесенько за все голосував віддавав
свої голоси він за все голосував за що
потрібно було служі народу і його за це
тримали більше того його навіть залишили
головою комітету з питань свободи слова
у Верховній раді що в серпні місяці
Минулого року більше року тому я подав
проект постанови Верховної Ради про те
щоб не брати все у ПСЖ з Верховної Ради
повністю і ми маємо абсолютно
конституційні підстави для цього більше
року мій проект не розглядається більше
року і ми набирали підписи на сайті
президента і все байдуже ніхто не хоче
влада це розглядати не розглядала і ще
раз більше року це питання і навіть далі
тримає Шуфрича головою комітету з питань
свободи слова України і російського
агента якого СБУ вже офіційно підозрює в
тому що якраз в інформаційному просторі
України він і працював проти України і
на Росію Друзі Ну от така історія
історія реального ну божевільна я про це
неодноразово говорив з трибуни Верховної
Ради шановні друзі Ви зараз хочете цією
постановою ще чергового опозиста ставити
в чергову комісію скажіть ну як Ну вам
Ну от вас нічого нема з цим ніяких
проблем ви не відчуваєте якісь проблеми
з цим ви не відчуваєте проблеми що ку
Поліщука продовжує тут в нас бути
головою комітету не Нестор ні літописец
можем Медведчук и нас залишається
народним депутатом України може Давайте
його зараз оберемо головою комітету
наприклад з національної безпеки Ну чого
Ні ну як це можна йти ви пояснити що
люди виключаючи тих яких нема в країні з
лютого місяця які виїхали до 24 лютого
напевно щось знали і вони продовжують
залишатися народними депутатами України
вам все гаразд все нормально інші
написали власноруч заяви про вихід з
фракції о ПСЖ подивились спочатку чи не
захопить Путін Київ побачили що не
захопив тоді написали заяви власноруч Це
пряма конституційна підстава позбавити
їх мандатів чого ви це не робите А зараз
ви Навпаки ще ставите їм переводити з
комітету в комітет тримайте на посадах Я
взагалі в комітетів Ви не хочете забрати
мандат зараз сумніваєтесь з
конституційності чогось так заберіть
хоча б посади які в них досить пір
залишаються ви нічого цього не робите Ну
як це можна пояснити Ну невже настільки
важливо що вони повністю здалися вам і
зручно готові за все голосувати Ну як це
це що достатньо підстава для вас щоб
тримати цей руський мір в українському
парламенті після всього що було після
кожної хвилини мовчання яку ви
оголошуєте на початку І ми стоїмо і
згадуємо наших героїв друзі Схаменіться
вигнать русские мир з українського
парламента зараз давно добивався щоби до
Шуфрича прийшли нарешті друзі це
відбулося будемо сподіватися що Шуфрич
нікуди не подінеться і будемо
сподіватися і понесе відповідальність по
закону а державна зрада це до 15 років
в'язниці І що прийдуть до його
спільників всіх цих інших опозистів які
продовжують сидіти в Верховній Раді
України друзі тримаємо стріхи хороші
новини нарешті опзж починають брати за
же треба далі нам з вами тиснути щоб
вони не зіскочили з цієї теми І щоб все
це не завершилося нічим як на жаль це
також в нас регулярно буває